[Music]
it's not complicated to see these two
are in love he was a skater boy and now
he's gonna be her husband which is
amazing from girlfriend
to fiance avril lavigne is engaged to
mod son so i'm just lucky to be next to
it they both shared pics of the romantic
proposal in paris
with the eiffel tower glittering nearby
mod got down on one knee and presented
avro with a unique diamond ring jewelry
experts suspect the 5 carat heart-shaped
sparkler costs north of 150 000
and just moments after mod popped the
question the happy couple was all smiles
with avril admiring her new bling
everything
to celebrate their happy ending the bite
me rocker and her fiance shared a
gondola ride complete with a violinist
and red roses that's a good time e.t
first learned the entertainers were
dating back in february 2021 after a
source revealed quote working together
has brought them closer and avril has a
history of falling for people that she
works with you'll recall avril was
previously married to some 41 frontmen
derrick whibley and nickelback's lead
singer chad kroger but when it comes to
avril and mod the duo linked up for his
track flames off his album internet
killed the rockstar
[Music]
fast forward to september they made
their red carpet debut as a couple at
the 2021 mtv vmas
that same month mod praised his fiancee
for having his back she's been like my
biggest supporter which is
not something i've ever
really had in my life before i miss
someone supporting me that much that
that i'm like that close with so to have
her in my life supporting me and helping
push me and you know she's the first one
that i play like music to now it's just
been crazy man i'm so lucky i know i'm
lucky i'm very lucky and just last month
at the iheart radio music awards avril
gushed over collabing with her beau we
made the album together like we co-wrote
the songs and he he'll produce and uh
and like he's coming out on tour with me
and like we do we're like super creative
together so it's really fun
haven't you heard
how we rock each
[Applause]
[Music]
be at the other